there's one thing i will tell you
uh that i think we don't pay enough
attention to so okay so i'm not the best
muslim but i'm a muslim right like for
me my parents were christians but i'm
like i'm an atheist there's no way in
the world i believe in a god with what
i've seen with bombs people dying
blowing up you're on all the sports i'm
like there's no god you guys are that's
for naive people but fine
if i say i'm a religion i'm a christian
because the lineage is the parents right
here's what you got to realize
if
your mom says what she said to him
that's the bible
meaning your mom becomes your god
let me let me unpack that a little bit
and i may be wrong just hear me out yeah
sure if a mom says
be careful with these western girls be
careful with this and be careful with
that be careful with that
and and the the
the form of affirmation was like not
once now she's probably told you that
many many times affirmations work and
then it sticks so for me
when i was uh uh
my dad and my mom got a divorce so it's
a slightly different story i don't know
they got divorced twice and i think they
were like legit wanted to get a divorce
but they kept coming back because maybe
this is gonna work out but they finally
got a divorce 20 years later
and my dad is a similar philosophy to
your mom so my dad and your mom are very
similar yeah okay with what he says
don't waste your time with all these
girls and let me tell you all the girls
lied and all the girls and you got to
realize my dad is my hero and i love my
dad my dad's probably listening to this
right now cracking up with him same same
at the house yeah so we got a great
relationship together but one day he
kept saying this you know women are this
and women are dead and women are this
and a relationship goes bad relationship
goes bad relationship goes bad
relationship goes bad and i'm finally
like screw this i'm just going to go
play and all this other stuff and i'm
like 26 27 28 and then we had a moment
and here's what the moment was
i start reading god knows how many books
i'm devouring books left and right that
became my like if i'm not going to
church my books became my god at 20 25
years old i eventually went to church
and i 25 26 whatever it was 2004 is when
i kind of started putting my life a
little bit more together trying to live
by some values but here's what what
happened one day my dad and i had a
moment i sat and i said okay
we give a little bit too much
credibility to our parents to know
everything and they don't we give a
little bit too much credibility to our
mom and dad that they know it all and at
one point we have to question like even
my kids they have to question some of my
philosophies and say daddy i don't know
what the hell you're talking about when
it comes down to xyz fine question it
right so i sat there and i said do my
parents love me check okay
do my parents without them there's no
way i'll be in america i'm indebted to
them for the rest of my life check
my parents food do i love it one million
percent check do i enjoy their company
check and i went through all this thing
do they know how money works hell to the
no so that's an x right okay do they
know there are 17 keys to marriage uh no
okay do they know how to eliminate their
in-laws from getting involved hell no
because their in-laws were a little bit
too involved and they kind of screwed
the whole thing up do they know the keys
to how to find the right husband or wife
no because back in the days it was more
deranged you know hey you made the you
know you come and you know kind of do
that
and then one day i come on my dad's like
let me tell you all girls are this i
said dad stop and we have to see you
know he knows the scene exactly so that
i don't want to hear it anymore i don't
want to hear this anymore don't pass
down your limiting beliefs to me you got
to stop that's your limiting belief okay
if that was your limiting belief and you
had a bad marriage or a bad life i don't
want to hear about it that's yours i
love my mom i love you but i don't want
that to be me do you want me to also go
through the same life he said no then
stop saying that to me so we had a very
i'm underestimating what this was it was
a very heated moment we didn't talk for
a week week later this is why my dad's
my hero because he's able to do this
he comes to me uh and my dad's an april
10 baby so he's like very much to
himself independent he doesn't rely on
anybody else he's he's his own man
and uh one day we're sitting there he
just it's quiet he says uh you're right
i said what he says you're right and my
dad won't say that he says you're right
i said what am i right with he says
you're right i've thought about it for a
week you shouldn't let my fears pass
down to you you're right
and i'm like holy freaking moldy right
i got the chills all over my body
because i love this man i love my mom i
want to live a good life i want to one
day give you grandkids but my dad also
said the following thing which is
exactly i can't say the whole thing what
he said he said listen before you get
married
date every single nationality
do it in every place you possibly can he
would say if you can do it in the phone
booth that's it that's not the 60s
he said you know you've made it when
you've done it in the phone booth and
you know playing all this other stuff he
goes through then when you get that out
of your system then it's a little bit
more where you're not going to be
sitting there saying hey you know i kind
of feel like i missed out then later on
you're like i kind of missed the party
life i'm definitely not going to have a
reputation i haven't missed a party live
yeah so that's the part so for your for
mom to say that
i mean in your religion my religion
where we come from from the middle east
iran mom is like you know for mom to say
that so i i fully understand that but i
think there's a there's a lot of depth
in your philosophies i don't think you
got to where you are right now
accidentally yeah no well so so um going
back to what you were saying there so
like no 100 like you know obviously you
can't let your parents viewpoints like
shape your world without necessarily
experiencing but what i was saying was
like when i was younger i was like i
challenged it then i was like what was
wrong with you like what the hell like
you know but as i became older i just
saw it through my own natural experience
what she said was true so it was a
little bit more profound for me because
i saw it through my own experiences
because at first i was like i don't know
if you're gonna be selective though
could that be selective could that be
just
uh uh accidental i wish it was man but
it's it's like you're young though
you're 32 years old you're still young
so here's the thing so we we um so at
this point we've interviewed well over a
thousand girls yeah and we and we've
noticed that there's certain trends in
certain uh mindsets certain beliefs
yeah and we always say you know just
because the hardware is different does
not necessarily mean the software is
going to be different the software is
almost always the same but the hardware
is different right and what i mean by
that is that in general there's this a
belief system
in first world countries you know where
feminism is strong where women think
that they're equal to you or a lot of
the times uh they don't necessarily want
to do certain duties that women used to
do before in other words your roles as a
man are static you're expected to be
masculine the protector the provider
central the leader but her roles are
negotiable she can pick and choose when
she wants to cook she can pick and
choose what she wants to be feminine she
can pick and choose when she wants to be
a lady and my thing is uh you know i
wasn't until i became older that i
realized that and then from interviewing
all the girls that we do going on dates
my anecdotal experience and then in
general talking we also talk with
thousands of men as well because we talk
with both men and women if you ever
watch our show we get super chats and
donations from all over the world and uh
you know it's always english-speaking
first world countries a lot of times you
know south africa australia new zealand
whatever and all these guys are dealing
with the same issues so i was like damn
okay so it's not just you know what my
mom said it's like now i actually see it
when my own two eyes were from any of
the girls from guys coming to us
and it's just like it's been reconfirmed
a million times over and over and now is
that to say that every girl is terrible
in the west don't marry them no i'm not
saying that but what i am saying is that
there's
tends to be this very similar mindset
when it comes to intersexual dynamics
with a lot of modern day women that
don't necessarily uh that won't lead to
a fruitful relationship if you don't
know what you're doing i think if
anything guys really got to be on your
p's and q's in today's day and age more
so than 20 years ago no i mean listen in
regards to that i i fully agree with you
but i will also tell you this listen
being in the investment world for 20
years uh uh i don't know how many times
i gave a hundred thousand dollars to
this deal fifty thousand dollars to this
deal two hundred thousand dollars and
nothing happened and also one of them
boom 28 million boom you get them and
you're like oh [ __ ] so none of this
stuff worked you know screw the
entrepreneur they help with the
investment none of these guys are
workers but you got to have a little bit
of that so of course i think the part
where
uh uh uh you know on in regards to the
parents when you're saying mom that all
that all that other stuff
they have um
i watched this video with this guy on
wendy williams he was in the movie black
panther who's the guy uh one of the
actors very good actor tyler can you
pull up black panther anyways this guy's
in chadwick bozeman
jordan uh no no there was another the
guy from creed uh uh oh man that's
michael b jordan no not him there's
another guy let me see can you go to the
imdb anyways he's on when you go to the
top because the pictures
daniel which one it is uh man i don't
know who was anyways a guy was on wendy
williams and when he's telling wendy
williams when i tell you to make a
sandwich you make me a sandwich who is
that guy i forget his name
what a great back and forth so yeah when
i tell you woman when i tell you to make
me a sandwich you make me sound serious
he's being dead
a woman
williams she says when i tell you to
make a sandwich a woman you make me a
sandwich like i'm not going to make you
sandwich oh okay okay let me get this
straight so if we go out to dinner do
you expect me to open the door yes when
we go out and take care of the bill do
you expect me to pay for it yes so when
we go out there and fight breaks out and
somebody says something do you expect me
to go i expect you to punch him in the
face well then when i expect you to make
me a sandwich you make me a sandwich do
you agree with him i do i do when jen
and i went on our date and we did the
101 questions i told jen
what do we went through this whole
question together because i've done this
exercise familiar with this book
anthony mackie the book that's the guy
yeah
he crushed it when when he get but he
was an eight mile i don't know if we can
play it don't play it don't play but
this is something that uh people have to
see but anyways
jen and i go to
we go through 101 questions and i said
look uh what what is your expectation of
me boom boom boom boom boom check check
check no problem no problem no problem
no problem here's what i expect from you
i don't care if my wife is black i don't
care my wife is white i don't care if my
wife is hispanic filipino whatever i
expect her to know how to make middle
eastern food
because my mom and my dad are only going
to be here for a while you got to make
my favorite dish that i like
and she's like okay i didn't have a lot
of requests my requests were like three
to five requests for your requests
i have the book i'll bring you one time
we'll go through the the request that i
had but i said this is one of the things
i the number of kids i wanted to have
the role the relationship you gotta have
the support anyways i went through but i
said that i want the uh middle eastern i
want my wife to know how to cook middle
eastern food because if the house smells
like food kids kids will stay home if a
dozen kids will leave so next date
she makes she goes on google makes an
assyrian dish
and i'm like
it was horrible
i mean it was the worst meals
but i sat there and i'm like eating the
food just to say i'm eating the food and
i told i said babe this is not good my
mom and dad can make it a million times
better but i have so much respect for
the fact that you didn't jump to and say
who am i i don't need to i'm not kidding
i'm like you know what hats off to you
but i tell you i can tell you 10 other
stories where that wasn't the case of
course you're right yeah
with other women yeah like i'm not going
to do that for you we're going to go out
there and do this no problem by the way
some people are listening to this and
they'll say well i still don't cook and
my husband cooks no problem that's part
of your arrangement
not mine i'm not gonna in our house i'm
not the handyman
right so i'm not the handyman i'm not
the guy no if you come to my house and i
asked senator the tico the other day
we had a conversation it's like dad you
know in school we have the same name
people think when i grow up i have to be
a businessman like you said no you don't
he says well why not i said dude you're
going to be whoever you want to be i
only want to see you do what you want to
do i'm 100 support you on what you want
to do as long as you're not breaking the
law as long as you're not hurting people
i got your back he says okay he says but
no that's not how it works i'm expected
to be like i said no you're not he says
so tell me why i said let me ask you a
question in the house when toys break
how often do you guys come to me he says
daddy you have no clue how to fix toys i
said who do you go to papa he fixes all
the toys
i said i can never be a handyman like
papa yes and i'm totally comfortable
with that we all have a certain strength
meaning there is that understanding of
what you expect from a girl that may be
different
felix is than yours if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]